i think what i'll do i'll play we'll
start with a random viewer
so anyone who's challenging me will have
a chance to
get a game please challenge me to
non-correspondence
so anything like ideally
five minutes or less but 10 minutes i
guess it's still okay
so i'm going to decline all the
challenges with no
no set time okay so a random challenge
hey playing xxx lucky star who subbed
earlier
good luck to my opponent
um obviously there is a reading
disparity but i'll try and be
instructive
maybe i'll play do i play like super
aggressively
let's do it england gabba time
so this is a more like serious time
control
ten plus five
so my opponent will have time to to
think but a lot of time to explain
things
and chat with the the chat
okay so i'm playing i did a video where
i showed this like this early bishop c5
line
but i'm playing kind of the og
[Music]
uh way of playing the england gambit i
attack the pawn twice
um basically attempting to provoke
bishop f4
verbal thanks for subbing at tier one
okay so we're going to get the main line
so queen b4
is a basically a triple fork
i'm guaranteed now to win b2
i think based on the amount of time my
phone is using
it's clear that this may be a new
opening for them
um so i'm gonna try not to say anything
too
revealing is this a wooden shield
or it's it's a tri tr
what's a word that starts with try
trident
or tricycle or triceratops
so white can defend two out of the three
things
mainly the bishop and the king oh a lot
of suggestions
trifecta or triangle
i don't think this is a shape of a
triangle
even though there's three lines are not
like fully connected in a triangular
triangular way okay so bishop d2 that
was probably the best move
now i'm hitting the rook um
so keeping some initiative also hitting
the pawn
yeah not much to okay so knight c c3 is
the best move
uh this is also prep i was gonna say not
much to
um to think about
because it is still prep um i'm kind of
disappointed my opponent didn't play
bishop c3
after which i would play bishop b4 and
there's some fun traps
against that
but bishop before continuing to make
threats
actually every move this game i've been
making threats starting with move one
like e5 i threatened to take then i
threaten the pawn
and then i trifecta triangle
and i take and attack the rook and then
i attack the knights
so i'm playing a lot of moves like
developing with attack
i will say uh this opening and even this
position
is objectively bad for black
but sometimes you have to do bad things
to
to have fun i guess
oh no my queen
so this move is a amman hamilton
variation
i think it's like the unofficial name
if you search for unbeatable opening
[Music]
on youtube or google you'll probably
find iman's picture
um and even though this position is like
if you turn on the engine it'll say like
plus three for white
but it's interesting because black gets
two minor pieces for the queen
white's a bit tied down knight's pinned
i think amman usually takes with a
bishop on e5
but for those who don't know ahman
hamilton is a grand master
uh chess bra
have a massive audience on twitch and
youtube
also kind of my roommate even though i
haven't seen him in
like about a year
we we technically share the same
apartment
um and he played this this opening in a
tournament game like a serious
grand master it was like a grand master
norm tournament
and he got to a drawn position ended up
losing after like over 100 moves
um maybe i'll have to show that game
after this game
but e4 okay um makes sense
i'll keep
i'll keep
now i'm attacking the pawn
so every move this game has either been
like a threat or a capture
like knight takes e5 is threatening
knight c4
e4 defended against that
but i'd really like to make use of this
pin
before white castles f3 is very solid
f3 could be weakening though because i'm
the only
player with a dark sword bishop
d5 comes to mind
now i should probably castle and then
later look to play d5
good sir haven't seen you in a while
school is
taking a toll welcome back
oh how do you do the
i'm conflicted here
i think i will
playing d5 castling may have been the
safer move
kind of opening the center with both
kings still
uncastled
but the threats i'm just keeping the
initiative basically
so i'm going to probably take twice i'm
not too scared about takes takes queen
e2 because the knight would still be
defended
i could still castle
also thank you to mat rob 91
hype for for six months
and remote.com213
submitting a tier one and rookie
mistakes welcome back something for 16
months
yeah thanks everyone appreciate the
support
so white's under under pressure here
actually i'm just realizing i didn't
realize it when i played pawn d5
but there's a positional idea just to
play pawn d4
cementing my bishop which is not going
to happen
okay so center is open no more center
pawns
the main goal is to get the rooks to the
center files
i might be threatening knights e3
it's a cool looking move hitting the
queen
it's like a nice square that's not
defended in white's territory
and if queenie two i'm assuming i got
two moves in a row but like 93 queen e2
take on c2 if king runs i
keep attacking the king
if king runs to d1
i could potentially play bishop f5
i'm having fun here oh but white's
trying to have fun
too so c6
i think is just the simplest move
white's trying to skewer my knights
i mean this knight's still defended by
the bishop
but yeah let's just play c6
i'm still keeping up my streak of
attacking something
or capturing something every move
and thank you to two more prime subs
llama attack and 13 philip 24.
appreciate it
okay so the rook moved back so i
essentially won a tempo there
because c6 was a more kind of beneficial
move for me
rook b3
kind of ties down my knight
but yeah i think i'll leave the bishop
there for the time being
i'll just castle castling would be the
first move that doesn't make
an immediate threat but the idea would
be to bring the rook in
and i think knight here is too risky
because i leave the bishop undefended
and
e-file could be a problem
if i got two more moves in a row
it would be checkmate the idea is to
play rook
e8 and knight d3 double checkmate
never mind oh white just uh is just
gifting me a
a bishop yeah it's easy to assume the
the c4 square is defended
but the lights pinned
and to put icing on the cake i can't
even get away with this
because when i take back i hit the queen
so there's no time to actually win the
night
oh i'm going to win the night too so
much icing
so now i have
oh now lee chess is saying i'm up
material
because i have a bishop another bishop a
knight
and a pawn for the queen
but in general like three minor pieces
are usually much
preferable over a queen as long as
they're coordinating
now pieces are actually really nice here
let's d2's targeted i'm about to have
four minor pieces for the queen i think
i'm realizing of white castles i'm gonna
have i'll have this fork
or that fork okay so
here i'll take
the queen the queen's almost trapped i
guess the queen has
a1 or c1 but it doesn't have
the light swears
so queen a1 yeah so that hits the knight
i'll counter-attack the king
i'm trying to calculate the best way to
convert this
so i have to do something about this
eventually
i guess white has a few choices here
but okay knight e4 i'll taken
[Music]
when the pawn keeps tracking the king if
king f1 i take the knight with check
king f2
okay don't have to worry about that
yeah the knight wasn't attacked f5 would
be nice but
okay so oh so i won the exchange
when i had the three miners for a queen
so now i have two miners and a rook
for a queen but the position is so so
nice
because the king is still a target
maybe i'll keep
the rookie ones coming
let's see where the king wants to go
if it moves here then the rook stuck if
it moves here then maybe there's some
mating ideas
and thanks for subbing cora the name
sounds italian
cora dopa chali
i just realized my opponent might end up
flagging too
okay so i could play g5 here like trying
to
orchestrate and mating that
also making some luft
but now so now i'm controlling all the
squares around the king
and all i need to do is check it with a
knight
so this is an idea
or check it with a pawn
okay white wants to check me
it's nice everything is pretty much
defended
except g5 but it's a hard pawn to attack
yeah rook have one good move thanks for
the games eric
oh thank you oh it's it's gary oh yeah
we played
we played so much earlier we played hand
and brain earlier actually shout out to
gary
hope you're doing well hope you have a
good stream too
oh danny streaming oh oh maybe i'll have
to raid danny soon
i haven't seen him stream in a while
okay let's um let's figure out how to
wrap things up here
and it's an awkward setup for like i
think i'll just bring the other rook in
going for rook t2
and then i'll target g2
[Music]
yeah even if i'm not like meeting
immediately
um i am
a material work have two good move
let me just play this we're going to
trade rooks
otherwise i have rook d1
so now this defends this defends this
defends this defends this
attacks this nice kind of chain
oh now i have this move
i'm guaranteeing to win something
something delicious
hey it's my first chess lesson today
thanks for getting me into chess
oh that's great to hear thanks for the
five dollars
more can
yeah my opponents may be inspired by
some of my previous
stalemate achievements but uh
nine months of tea and chess oh
congratulations the dark lock rises
now a baby well thanks for the game xx
lucky star
7xx uh that was a fun one this is um
i mean this is kind of the main prep in
the england gambit
and if you check this position okay
it's pretty common in the leeches
database
a few thousand games but then the
masters database
there's one game by
amman hamilton himself
[Music]
and this is a game it was played in st
louis i think amman was just kind of
trolling
but it's interesting like two minor
pieces are
they can surprisingly put up a good
fight against the queen
and this is a super long game so i'm
just zooming through it but
yeah black just kind of held held his
own
light gave some material and then at
some point
yeah then it was queen versus rook
but black had close to a fortress
this is a super long game
at some point it was a table-based draw
maybe here yeah it's some like crazy
table-based draw
but uh
anyway like if you play the england
gambit like this is probably one of the
the better practical lines to go for
and then like as white
usually what you should do is just
castle as quickly as possible
so e3 might be a better move yeah like
e3 you still control the square
castle and then get the knight out of
the pin
so anyway that might be youtube worthy
and playing
playing the unbeatable england um
because i don't have i don't really have
any videos where i
go for this line so if you're watching
in the future on youtube um
i usually leave a link to like any game
i play in a youtube video i'll leave a
link
in the description for people to to
analyze
basically this analysis board also leave
links to my twitch
channel and twitter and instagram and
other fun things